now as somebody who didn't grow up with
the internet now seeing what it is your
kids are growing up with it yeah right
yeah um how do you shield them from
it's crazier parts of it with the
it's everything from bullying to you
know god forbid you come you come home
one day and you're you see your
daughter's son and they're watching the
whitney cummings on the internet
what do you do
you know like how do you handle
as a father
how do you handle all this
no it's actually it's actually true well
not the whitney thing true um no like my
daughter's watching you know she said to
me the day she said dad can i get
tick-tock and i go absolutely not and
she's like but i'll just and this is
what let me know that it's [ __ ]
horrible right she goes no i'll just go
to the things that i want to see no dude
they're doing stuff they're doing gross
[ __ ] there's a lot of sexual [ __ ] up
there my daughter's ten man yeah you
know and there's problems and the kids
are locked in the phones big man my son
is you know my son is he does watch a
lot of basketball stuff and youtube
stuff but my son has got his head down a
lot right to the point where i'm like
buddy buddy i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] talking
to you like my dad that didn't happen
with us no you know we stared at the
window and
yeah no there was nothing to stare at
other than your life
yeah you had to kind of live in what was
yeah in in in in they're happier than i
than than we were oh the kids yeah yeah
they're happier and yeah they're yeah
they seem happier my kids are happy my
kids are happy they're just distracted
but i don't want them i'm fighting it
i'm i'm fighting it so you're gonna find
out do you think you get worn down
eventually do you think it breaks down
like
when they get into the teen years
because all of their friends are gonna
be doing this
so at what point do you
i don't know do you give in or do you
how does it work
well here's the thing you know the i
think the italian in me i i kind of i
kind of bribe right cash is cash is king
in the house right so i told my daughter
my daughter was on the couch he'll love
this yeah
uh my daughter's on a couch with stacey
and she goes i want an iphone and you
know stacy goes well lucas got an iphone
after fifth grade you've got to wait
till fifth grade right she goes but i'm
different than lucas i want an iphone
so her soccer team didn't win a game oh
yeah and they scored one goal all season
it was terrible they never won we would
travel to yonkers we would travel to
dobbs fair
embarrassment to seven o'clock in the
morning there's dew all over the thing
i'm exhausted i'm yelling at my wife why
i had to get up so early i got coffee in
my hand and they get blown out we get
back in the car shameful yeah right get
in the car and we would just wouldn't
talk about the game we'd go get lunch
right so
uh they score one goal all year it's the
last game they haven't won a game so i
just out of nowhere i go sophia
you score a goal tomorrow morning and
you score a goal in the game tomorrow
morning get you an iphone 11 whatever it
was
first
first half she's dragging ass all the
kids are right yeah it's all over
they're losing the money stays in my
pocket money stays them up and now
parents start hearing about it the
parents there's rumblings yeah hey dude
versi just [ __ ] versy told sophia you
know we're losing dude second half
starts she starts running the ball
ricochets it's in front of her it's just
her and the goalie she lofts it up over
the goalie's head it goes in all the
parents start going nuts everyone
sophia's running down in the middle of
the game tim middle of the game she goes
dad iphone 11. and everybody [ __ ]
went nuts but you know i'm telling my
kid listen you and some people don't
like the parent i told my kid you scored
20 tonight you're gonna get cash right
you know i said you get honor roll you
get 300 cash and we're going to go get
you the sneakers no it's smart do you
ever when the when the team's not doing
good you ever grab the coach and go like
what are we doing here
you know what i mean like do you ever
grab the coach you're like listen i'm
getting up early seven weeks in a row
and nothing's changed like are we do you
have a plan do we have any plan as to
how to get out of this like
you know like they had a game in queens
by randall's island yeah a team that
never loses yeah and
we actually had the decency to just
cancel it
[Laughter]
no the parents had a meeting and they go
we're not driving we're not all driving
down to queens to get to do that so
let's just let's forfeit now so we could
go out and drink tonight and they and
the parents did they canceled it there
were two types of parents sports parents
when i was coming up there was the
parents who
didn't care when they were just like
this is a babysitter
these three hours a week that you're
gone are three hours i don't have to see
you yeah and then there were parents who
would physically attack the coach and
referee if they didn't like the calls
yeah yeah like it was those two extremes
and very few in the middle it was either
like hey have fun we don't really care
yeah the other extreme was that you know
there are literally if you google this
ben yeah yeah there was and these were
like connected guys in long island
everybody thinks they're connected it's
you know yeah yeah um they went down
two guys attacked a baseball co a
baseball coach long island they went on
to the field
they literally were like what the [ __ ]
going on
and they um
yeah right there right here in 2007.
brothers busted for a beat down of long
island
baseball coach and it was like a uh i
remember this in in in 2007
and basically it was like an 11 year old
baseball player
upset over being benched
uh for cursing and batting practice
called his father who drove to the
bellmore ball field rushed the mound
with his brother
pummeled the coach
sending him to the hospital
police said wednesday
the brothers frank basile and roger
bastille who own a restaurant i love
called hudson and mccoy or used to
were arrested and charged i think they
do it was a great i just enjoy it
um
they were arrested and charged tuesday
this was years and years ago
with whatever
you know how funny is that when they're
in the holding cell yeah what did you
get i was doing dope no no i beat the
[ __ ] out of a little league cup yeah we
[ __ ] just keep my kids couch
and you know because their sons get they
benched them for being like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like you have to be on the
bench no there was there was another one
where the parents go come on and the guy
the guy goes uh if you do one more thing
and he just left he he left he took the
mask off and the ump just left i'm not
no we don't you know right i don't uh i
don't do that yeah it's a lot in long
island i don't even know
in long island it happens
100 percent all that like what people do
for children sports is insane yeah and
it's such and all it is is a projection
of their of what's going on with them
which is right because they regret maybe
they go maybe they're trying to relive
their glory days or they never they
regret you know not their parents didn't
push them more
yeah and they're like maybe if i push
the kids we can get them there was a guy
i think in our district or the town over
he eight eight year olds he kicked a
soccer ball say go get it [ __ ] it
freaked out he was just never he was
banned from the field he wasn't allowed
not he wasn't allowed on the property
like he he wasn't allowed to be seen he
wasn't allowed to be seen on the
property like they were just like this
guy can't even like not only
not only are you not doing this anymore
like you can't be seen people can't see
you anymore
so what was he doing he was just telling
eight-year-olds
he was uh i guess i guess uh he was just
telling eight-year-olds something and
they weren't listening and i guess he
just had a breaking point of losing yeah
you know because there's only so much
you could take do you ever no do you
coach no no i don't know but if i but
like one time i ran like intramurals
yeah where they broke up our our whole
team and yeah and i did and the kids
like you know i know like i could tell a
kid that like is just going through like
takes it real seriously where i'll be
like dude just go you know like i was
able to read these guys want to win for
them right not the kid right so this guy
probably my guess is he probably lost 13
weeks in a row you know you know his
wife is saying something right i've seen
wives actually like go up to the husband
while they're coaching and be like can
you do something can you do something
yeah interesting you know because
they're at breakfast and he's yelling
and she's like why don't you win a
[ __ ] game you don't think he's taking
that in the car that's competitive he's
getting in the car going thinking like
this so um this kid kicked a ball i
think i heard he kicked a soccer ball i
don't know what the [ __ ] it was he
kicked a soccer ball far and started
saying you get it you [ __ ] like it
was like and people were like yeah he's
just never coming back you know
jesus yeah and then but then that guy
shows up like
yeah to the auditorium for the school
play yeah everybody's like yeah hey
harry there he is